hi Dean Green here bill I wanted to ask
you a hypothetical if the moon was
really made out of green cheese how much
mass would it have what would its
gravity be like how would it affect our
ties differently than the real moon does
and just for fun how much milk would it
take to make that much green cheese
thanks for your answer
Dan a great question about the moon
being made of cheese specifically I
understand a green cheese if it were
green cheese like really green I would
expect it to reflect a little more green
light than it does I mean it would
depend it doesn't have a rind does it
have that wax that they put on in the
cheese shops not sure anyway I can tell
you from experience that in general
cheese floats in general so with
floating cheese you got to figure its
specific gravity that is to say how much
mass it has for how much volume it takes
up is somewhat less than rocks rocks
what if water is one rocks are one and a
half they're two they're twice as dense
as water they're not 50 times as dense
twice as dense Rock sink but they don't
sink like a bullet so it a moon that was
80 percent the mass of the current moon
would have 80 percent of the effect on
the tides but if it were 80 percent of
the fat of the mass its orbital distance
would probably be different would it be
set up to lie bait in the same way that
is to say the moon currently keeps the
same face to us with every orbit and
that has to do that's because it spins
almost exactly one time as the Gores
goes around the Earth it spins has a
little wobble to it we actually see
somewhat more than just half of the moon
if you're really diligent with the
telescope paying close attention and
then the other thing I would wonder
about a cheese moon you know rocks rocks
are pretty solid but cheese often is not
I wonder if it wouldn't have
loads or vibrational oscillations within
its own shape that are noticeable I
wonder if it's spin wouldn't spending
once with each orbit I wonder if it
wouldn't have an equatorial bulge I
wonder if what would happen to when
other cheesy objects hit it you know
meteorites of cheese cheese your rights
whatever they're called and I wonder if
it wouldn't out gas or evaporate in the
blackness of space also cheese freezes
so on the the far side of the moon or
the near side depending on the time of
month you might have some lunar freezing
which then would have could potentially
affect the shape because it would affect
its its gravity with one side saw
changing density and the relative to the
other side the geode as it's called the
shape would change with its own gravity
so there'd be some issues you'd notice
it right away
and I think another issue to keep in
mind if the moon turns out to be made of
cheese it just really expands our
possibilities for a lunar base and it's
all the RINO because there be sort of
limitless food it does for those of you
who are gluten-free and dairy-free you
may not want to be an astronaut on a
lunar mission now if it turns out that
it's made of green cheese